huh but one day your old pal Wade's
going to ask you to get back in the
saddle
again and when he does say
yes oh right we have just learned a lot
more about what Deadpool 3 is
specifically going to be about plus
secret Wars also the plot of Deadpool 3
might tell us a little bit about how
season two of Loki is going to end and
everything is really starting to feel
more connected now going into the end of
loky season 2 going into dead bull 3 and
then eventually leading into Avengers
Secret Wars something else that is
really great is that we have learned
that the variance that we are going to
be seeing in Deadpool 3 in Avengers
Secret Wars or anywhere else in between
in the multiv ver Saga in the MCU are
pretty much going to be the best
versions of those characters and as it
turns out there is a specific reason we
are going to be seeing the best versions
of these variants all come together in
the Marvel cinem atic Universe what's
going on everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson and
we've learned a lot about Deadpool 3 and
Secret Wars and we're going to break it
all down in this video including some
major Wolverine details about Deadpool 3
and why and how characters like
Wolverine Toby Maguire Spider-Man maybe
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Patrick
Stewarts Professor Xavier and many other
awesome characters that we have seen in
the previous Marvel franchises are going
to be brought into the MCU and stick
around until Avengers Secret Wars is
over two big reports to dive into today
so let's get started but if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news and today
is the last day of our giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox series X A PS5
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items all you got to do is subscribe and
leave a comment on our videos the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick one
winner every single month now at this
point we can pretty much paint a full
picture of what Deadpool 3 is going to
be about and if you've been following
the channel and all the news you know
that there's a lot of crazy stuff that's
been rumored to happen happen in this
film but the good news is an Insider
today has clarified that the movie is
still very much about Deadpool and
Wolverine yes we can expect some cameos
director Shawn Levy has already
confirmed this but it's still going to
focus on the two main characters
Deadpool and Wolverine and the first
report is coming from my time to shine
hello who tweeted yesterday Deadpool 3
is about the TVA picking up the prime
versions of each hero to create a
multiversal army to fight the Kings now
this is only part of the report we'll
finish it in a bit but just want to add
that we knew this was going to happen
but we didn't know about the prime
versions of each character and I really
like this idea because this opens up
essentially the story to go into the
Multiverse way more than we've done it
before because one thing that we heard
before was that Deadpool is going to be
searching the Multiverse to find the
best version of Wolverine until he
eventually decides that Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is the best and he
sarcastically States while at the same
time breaking the fourth wall that Hugh
Jackman cannot be recast so this
explains why Deadpool was going to see a
bunch of different versions of Wolverine
but ultimately end up with hu Jackman
because they are searching for the best
one but my time to shine hello continued
in her tweet by stating and they picked
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine to recruit but
he's not fully on board that is what the
movie is about now this really does help
clarify some things before we knew that
the TVA was going to be grabbing
characters from different universes
rumor had it that they were doing this
and kind of creating somewhat of a
Noah's Arc for the Multiverse
essentially incursions were happening
all throughout the Multiverse universes
were being destroyed and the TVA was
essentially saving the best characters
from each Universe putting them in one
universe so they could ultimately
restore and fix the Multiverse after
defeating kangs however now we know that
the TVA is specifically recruiting a
multiversal army we've talked about this
before sort of a Multiverse Avengers
team that will consist of not only just
the Avengers but the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four and of course probably
some villains as well I'm sure there's
going to be a good version of Magneto
out there somewhere in the Multiverse
and the same could be said for Dr Doom
and others but this is good
clarification because it means that the
TVA can take people from universes that
aren't exactly about to die because that
was a lot of people's main concern well
if our characters from our main 616
Universe like Spider-Man Doctor Strange
the Scarlet Witch the Hulk whoever they
may be taking from our universe that
means that they're not going to be the
only survivors that means our universe
doesn't necessarily have to be on the
brink of Destruction in order for the
TVA to grab some Heroes which means that
everything that has happened in our
universe doesn't have to be reset and
forgot about now the MCU is looking to
do a soft reboot but perhaps they could
still stay in the 616 Universe it could
just simply be altered by the events
that happened in Avengers Secret Wars
and Deadpool 3 so really this is great
news and I can't wait to see this huge
multiversal Army that the TVA is is
putting together which Loki might very
well be in charge of by the end of Loki
season 2 it might be determined that
Loki is going to be the ruler of the TVA
we've been talking about this for a
while now on the channel but that could
be Loki's glorious purpose so Loki could
be behind the TVA and it could actually
be his and Mobius is idea to gather all
of these different heroes from the
different universes to fight Kang and
his variants and we have one more report
from Ken we get some toast going into
more detail about Deadpool 3 we'll talk
about that in just a bit but first big
thank you to fume for sponsoring this
video fume is a GameChanger for a lot of
people in turning bad habits into good
habits a lot of people struggle with
these bad habits but fume looks at these
in a different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually raved about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to trif nume.com and use code
Cosmic to save 10% off when you get the
journey pack today that's TR
f.com and use code Cosmic to save save
an additional 10% off your order today
so the second report coming from can we
get some toast says this to be clear
Deadpool 3 is still very much a Deadpool
movie his Antics with Cable's time
machine caught the tva's attention and
he became their prisoner now of course
this part is talking about the post
credits for Deadpool 2 where Deadpool
takes Cable's time travel device and he
goes and he changes a lot of stuff in
the past and as we've learned from Loki
season 1 that is really not cool to them
so of course it makes sense that the TVA
would go and capture Deadpool so he goes
to the TVA and he becomes their prisoner
because it doesn't seem like after Loki
season 2 at least they really execute
judgment and just prune people anymore
so it looks like Deadpool is simply
going to be a prisoner there but the
second half of this report States this
when Deadpool learns about the tva's
plan for a multiversal army it gives him
the motivation to escape and try to
convince Hugh Jackman's Wolverine to
come with him now this is where we can
assume he goes go to a bunch of
different universes seeing a bunch of
different variants of Wolverine until
ultimately he decides H Jackman's
Wolverine is the main one the prime one
who cannot be replaced now ultimately of
course there is going to be a villain of
the movie it could be a king variant or
it could be a very specific Deadpool
villain but we know that this is going
to go directly into Avengers Secret Wars
and the team that the TVA makes in
Deadpool 3 is basically going to be our
team of Avengers and other Heroes that
takes on the Council of King in secret
Wars and from what it sounds like we are
going to get the best of the best
variants and of course these variants
could be characters that we've never
seen in the MCU and actors that we've
never seen in the MCU as well as the fox
universe or anything that Sony has done
for that fact we've heard Toby Maguire
Spider-Man is going to be coming back
we've heard Hugh Jackman is going to go
into Secret Wars as well plus a lot of
the original X-Men are going to be
joining as well and hopefully a good
amount of new characters that we've
never seen before so Deadpool 3 in
secret Wars really is is shaping up to
be exactly what we wanted from the
Multiverse Saga and I am personally
super excited especially as we learn
more and more about Deadpool 3 and
Avengers Secret Wars but let us know
your thoughts in the comments down below
are you excited are you not and who are
you most excited to see as a variant let
us know your thoughts and don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
wolf